[Music]
the fans of The Voice you're gonna have
to wait until February 27th now we all
remember a few seasons ago we watched
Blake and Quinn's romancing night on the
show well now we get to see if their
love can survive with full season ahead
the banter it takes us back to a time on
the boys when these two first became
official remember season nine and and
then there's Blake who again is very
sasquatch that's now the guns back as a
coach there'll be more of that and even
though there's a lot of love right there
when it comes to winning the voice all
bets are off in this competition I only
have one go when it comes to this show
to win with an artist this feels so good
to say to that person underneath you
could do this I'd love to see people
work hard and make it stay on top of the
steps to be competitive but it's more
about nurturing these people and their
dreams
Suzy 12 celeb mentors include Celine
Dion John Legend Luke Bryan and DJ
Khaled when's filling the seat left
vacant by Miley Cyrus making this the
second time the shows have two female
coaches and all we can say is the guys
better watch out
I know two women coaches is really
working as you
[Applause]
you